Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 2 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get
all the episodes and careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet,
just starting
at the beginning of the episode,
working our way through, shot by shot,
talking about Easter eggs WTF moments,
starting with the episode title
The Generic Trap,
which is a reference to the Parent Trap.
it's meant to be another Rick
and Jerry adventure,
where they both at their brains mixed up.
They tend to do Rick and Jerry episodes
at least once or twice per season
since season three.
this is mostly so that they can have Jerry
act more like Rick, like
he can be a more badass version of Jerry
instead of just the regular punching bag
that he usually is.
usually one of the other tropes of Rick
and Jerry episodes is them slowly
growing like a little bit closer each
time is friends, like in this episode.
Jerry Ford admits
that Rick is like one of his best friends
or the closest thing to a best friend,
they let Jerry be a little more badass,
like every once in a while.
But usually they try to reset him back
to being the family's punching bag like,
they don't want to get to Opie.
Like in the opening scene, there's him
going for Jean-Claude Van Damme.
Every once in a while.
He has a moment, kind of like that.
But then it's quickly back to loser.
Jerry.
Probably the other biggest reveal
the episode, though, is that
Morty has become a full on drug dealer
at some point
has this whole network of black
market contacts the world of crime
or the multiverse for some reason,
or he's been doing it for Rick and that's
how he's gotten all these contacts.
they just make it seem like it.
All of these scenes is part of that
subplot.
He's super dark.
However long he's been doing this.
They make it seem like
it's been going on for a while,
but it seems like
it's been relatively recent.
Let me know in the comments.
How long do you think that Morty has been
dealing Crystal's The cold open is Jerry
trying to get Rick to help him get his rag
back from Jean, who he thinks stole it?
Because the whole idea is
the jury is meant to be spineless.
love that Rick's first solution is just
to give him the guy and just go shoot him.
Go kill him, Take the Rick back.
That way,
the only weird thing here, though,
is that you find out
there's a projectile gun later.
Like normally
you think that Rick would give him,
like, a laser gun,
like some sort of beam weapon.
Projectile
weapons are kind of beneath him.
then they set the whole Freaky Friday
premise of the episode with Jerry trying
to shame Rick for being born a genius
and Rick trying to explain that it's
more of a nurture thing,
not so much nature.
Like you're not born a genius,
you just work really, really hard
to become even more intelligent.
there's a lot of real world science
that you could use to argue
for both different points.
But in a lot of cases
it is possible to be born
with the higher potential for intellect.
but in most cases usually the nurture
like the environment you grow up in
makes up a lot of that difference.
so there are a lot of potentially
really intelligent people out there
who are very young.
They just don't get the education
that they need
to become incredibly intelligent people.
I also think Rick is kind of implying here
like he's making fun of Jerry,
but also implying
that Jerry could have become a genius
had he studied hard enough
when he was younger.
is also making fun of Jerry
for not being able to handle the real
situation on his own because Gene is like
an even bigger punching bag on the show.
like he's meant to be below Jerry
in terms of like a level on the show.
notice when he's constructing the device
to swap their minds Freaky Friday style
is actually his suicide helmet
that he winds up taking parts from
and changing things
like he's got two of them
so you can let me know who you think
he was planning on using the second helmet
for before he changed the device
just to swap their minds
that's been in the garage
since like season one.
There've been so many theories
about that since season one.
was he going to use it for?
Was he cooking zoom in.
Enhanced notice that the device is powered
by the same type of crystals that Rick
has Morty selling that they wind up
snorting later in the episode.
they're kind of like Clancy and crystals.
But there are different colors.
They're not actually Claxton crystals
like a totally different type of crystals,
like the other crystals
also that help you see your future
that are totally different as well.
now there are at least like three
different types of really important
crystals in the Rick and Morty multiverse.
there
couple points later in the episode two
where Morty also jokes
that you can use the crystals
for multiple different things,
like they're not just dr*gs,
you can also use them for other things
because Rick is using them
to power his device here.
Jerry
willingly admits that he's unwilling
to admit his own failures.
Like he'd
rather go through this experiment
than admit to his own failures because
there are so many of them on the Daily
the funny bit when they swap minds.
And Rick would rather kill himself
than live with Jerry's mind.
So he used the gun that he tried
to give to Jerry earlier.
and because Jerry doesn't understand
how to work Rick's body
with all the inspector gadget of it,
all he wants of accidentally
killing himself to the one of
the weird parts of this bit, too, is
when the garage guy comes out and laments
that it's going to lose his Thursday,
like I had plans,
what were the actual plans
that it was going to have
instead of
putting their brains back together?
Like what was the garage
I going to do instead of doing this?
I've already explained all the new intro
scenes during my episode one video.
None of them are featured during episode
one or episode two,
so we'll see if they show up in future
episodes.
Morty gets captured for selling the space
crystals on the space Mafia's territory.
No idea what Rick was going to do
with all those space crystals,
but he explains they were like,
ten different briefcases worth
that they had during the episode.
So whether he was going to go on
like the world's biggest bender
or he was going to power
something really, really big with it,
this is the first time
that we've been to this place, crime town.
It just seems like a random
black market center for the mafia.
Like this is a mafia settlement
because they have an open air
crime restaurant where everybody is
a criminal.
there's this whole running date with
the mob boss being afraid of Rick Sanchez.
Like, what is Morty?
He's related to Rick Sanchez.
We have to let him go immediately.
the couple weird bits
that they give to the mob boss.
You like when he's yelling at everybody?
Like he yells at this one,
calling him a big, precious moron?
I think the idea is that he's either
supposed to be super close to this person
or he thinks of them as close friend.
Or is this a really nice mob boss?
the characters voiced by Ryan Ridley,
who also used to write on the Rick
and Morty Show in the early seasons,
but he left to do other shows
and just comes back to do voices
every once in a while.
There are a lot of people
on Rick and Morty like that
who like since come back to the show after
leaving for a couple of seasons, it's
kind of the same thing
with other really long running shows
like The Simpsons where like people will
come on for a couple seasons,
then the lead in will come back
many, many seasons later
when he calls Rick chaotic, neutral,
that's actually pretty accurate.
Rick does both good and evil
things in equal amounts.
when he says Rick would turn him
into a sandwich, that's just a reference.
Back to Pickle.
Reagan is like an example of the show
referencing itself, like Mr.
Poopy Butthole broke the fifth wall,
which is when the show,
like, literally references itself
like an actual episode.
You didn't watch Season four
referencing his previous episode
that's also something that a lot of long
running shows like The Simpsons do,
like they eventually get very,
very self-referential,
like not just referencing things
in real life, but actually referencing
earlier moments on the show
that you would have have to watch.
apparently he also has like six to go
bags, like he's constantly ready
to drop everything and go into hiding
with a bag full of supplies.
weirdly, though,
he knows all about Rick Sanchez
in being from Earth,
but he doesn't know what milkshakes are,
even though he seems to know
a lot about Earth
when the garage aliens winds up
putting their minds back together,
it mixes them up like turns them
into hybrid versions of themselves.
is that Rick is drooling a little bit.
There were a lot of people
that asked about this during episode
one about the lack of Rick's
drooling early on Dan
and just in like many, many seasons ago,
actually explained
this is a more practical animation kind
of thing they said after the first season.
Rick drooled so much that they actually
started to dial that back in animation
just because they felt like
he had become too big of a thing
But before they actually explain
this practical change, fans
actually came up with this theory
that you were actually watching
a different Rick.
Like if you saw Rick in an episode
and he wasn't drooling, then the episode
was meant to follow a Rick
from another dimension, not C-130s.
Seven Rick That could still be true.
But I think it's
more of a practical thing.
Like they just wanted to be drooling every
single second of every single episode
in the reminder here
is that the two hybrid, different versions
basically have equal amounts
of each other's brains,
even though they got slightly
different pieces of each other's minds,
which is why they both think of themselves
as Rick in both of them hate
the idea of being thought of as Jerry.
Generally, this is
where we get to like Star Trek territory
with the Tuvix episode.
If you didn't see Tuvix,
they basically did
this plot on Star Trek
in a couple of different Star Trek series.
The whole idea is
they become like completely new people
with new personalities, new memories
that they create for themselves,
like whole new lives.
in in order
to make things like they used to be, you
essentially have to kill these two people.
they just did this bit during Star Wars
lower decks, which itself was meant
to be a parody of an earlier
Star Trek Voyager episode called Tuvix,
where Tuvok and Neelix got mixed together
and became a single person.
the whole idea in the episode
and they parodied
this during the lower decks episode
is that Janeway basically had to kill
that new person to bring back her officers
and make things the way they used to be.
Jerry makes
an R2-D2 reference
when he says R2-D2 freezing.
That's just a joke
about all the different times
during the Star Wars movies
when R2-D2 will seemingly not be able
to do something or forget to tell them
critical information when they need it,
like the whole idea is that R2-D2
remembers everything from the prequels.
So he could have told
Luke Skywalker and Obi-Wan
everything the minute that he met them,
but he did not.
There's a bit of a running gag
about the mob boss
having met Rick like, ten times.
But Rick doesn't care to remember him.
That's pretty much true.
Of all the people around the multiverse.
Like Rick runs
into all these different people
through the course of his ventures
and just does not care about them at all,
they make a Liam Neeson taken reference
when Rick references telling the gangsters
that they're supposed
to tell them where they are.
Like, We know where you are.
You don't have to tell us.
We will find you.
And Rick also kind of confirms
that he tries to actively
cultivate a mystique
about himself around the multiverse,
revealing that he does really care about
how everyone thinks of him, despite
telling everyone that he doesn't care
what people think.
the 1930s comedy act
that he references is Laurel and Hardy.
and when they crash through the mob boss's
window.
Noticed the art on his wall.
This looks like a Han Solo Star Wars
Carbonite reference like Jabba the Hutt.
He's a crime boss.
So he had something similar, like a person
actually hung up on his wall.
The person escaped.
So now here's the indentation in this
left, kind of like jabba's carbonite
they make a whole bunch of gay
jokes in the episode.
There are a couple layers here too.
So like first,
he was calling Jerry Gay to call him gay,
but because they both acknowledged
that they're the same,
he's kind of slowly admitting
that he's also kind of gay himself.
I think the idea is Rick is just pansexual
because he'll have sex
with pretty much anything
that moves. Even robots.
they turn into like a much bigger idea,
like everyone is a little gay joke,
like sexuality is a spectrum.
it winds up turning into like
a much bigger Seinfeld kind of joke.
Not that there's anything wrong with that.
No, of course not.
I mean, it's fine if that's who you are.
Absolutely.
Rick makes it sound like them
capturing Morty and botching whatever
Crystal deal he had Morty doing or what
He was in the middle of cost.
Rick Like ten times what they're offering.
So like I said,
no idea what he was going to use
all those crystals for
and because of Walter White's Crystal
Blue during the Breaking Bad series,
they make a Breaking Bad reference.
The mid-tier crime
dork is also a reference to the villains
on the Breaking Bad show that Walter White
and Jesse usually ran into.
Rick refers to himself as a God.
He's done this many times.
He also fought God, a.k.a.
Reggie, and killed him
back in season four.
He was the closest thing to like the one
true God in the Rick and Morty multiverse.
But Rick is also an atheist in
his previously said that there is no God.
so just meant to be a joke about all
the contradictions that reside inside.
Rick Like he himself
is like a walking contradiction, almost.
they've kind of gotten into this
in the Marvel movies now, too,
because they're like actual God characters
walking around.
But you also have characters
in the Marvel Universe
who are atheists, unlike The Avengers
and the other big teams,
like How can you be an Atheist?
Yet there is a walking, living
God standing next to you here
they make a couple Coneheads
jokes during the episodes.
Rick having a Coneheads phase
where he walked around
having an actual cone in the Coneheads
joke actually started.
That is an old SNL skit
way back in the day.
Then they turned it into a movie
and they're mostly referencing the movie
during the episode.
it's also one of the rare examples
of Rick and Jerry agreeing on something
that they both mutually like.
They both love Coneheads
and when they referenced the cast,
the movie being amazing, they're more
a compliment being the SNL actors,
because it was people from the SNL skit
that did the movie and Chris Parnell,
the voice of Jerry used to be on SNL.
probably one of the biggest things
that he'd be known for from SNL
was the Lazy Sunday skit.
It was like one of the first
big skits they posted online.
they pay off the conehead joke with Rick
killing Chuck Foley, the mob boss,
by running him in
because pointy head conehead
setting up the bit
at the end of the episode with him
dying from the wound, then
apparently they're both weirdly obsessed
with cheeseburgers.
But the bit about them
wanting to make a super burger
made up with all the different patties
is an actual real thing.
So like one of the very first jobs
that I ever had when I was a little kid
was working at McDonald's.
And we actually did stuff like this
like you take all the different types
of meat patties and you make a super Big
Mac like a Quarter Pounder, a Big Mac,
it was like 10,000 calories
and it tasted amazing.
they wind up naming their team up burger
and fries for their love of cheeseburgers.
And that's their whole bit,
their calling card.
They put cheeseburgers in people's mouths,
was they also pay
off at the end of the episode
when the mob boss dies.
Like how long you've been keeping
this cheeseburger in your pocket. There.
The beer that they're drinking
here, too, is Rick's usual brand.
They've had it in many,
many seasons up to this point.
they make, a few Matthew McConaughey jokes
about taking it easy,
just hanging loose.
You'd call that a joke
on any of his movies.
He's pretty much like that
at some point in all of his movies.
They learned Jerry was
right about Jean stealing his rake,
which he later admits to.
And they give Jean this weird moment
of self-actualization.
Later in the episode where he comes
clean about everything that's been
bothering him for like the many,
many seasons that he's been on the show.
but then by the end of the episode,
they turn him back into the punching bag,
even though it's like
the memory version of Jean, like,
we don't want Jean getting too
big here, too powerful in the show.
don't want to pay him
too many compliments.
Rick's old joke about the chat room
and women calling in both their father
and husband just implies that he's got it
with a ton of much younger women
that think of him
because he's so much older
as their father, but also their lover.
then when Beth makes the joke about
breakfast in school not really mattering,
that's mostly them clowning on themselves
because the whole school,
like there's this whole idea that
Morty and Summer go to school every day.
They're still in high school,
so they have to go to school every day.
But they actually references way earlier
on the show when Morty told Rick that
he actually be held back a grade because
Rick kept pulling him out of school.
There's also a moment like this
at the end of the episode
to where best like I get
I get to go suck up some horses,
like she has to go back to her job
because Beth also has a normal day job
that she goes to every day,
even though they don't show it very often.
the whole burger and fries bit
with the Hawaiian shirts
and the crime spree
feels like it's right out of like Scarface
or some other movie like Pulp Fiction.
You can let me know what you think.
This is a reference to this kind of
seems like a space version of Miami.
So I was thinking Scarface.
There's also Tony's Laundromat here
for like Tony Montana
during their actual heist,
when they're stealing all the crystals,
they play some synth music
that sounds kind of like the music
from Scarface
And apparently they've been doing this
for a while.
Like, it's a bit of a montage
because one of them keeps getting shot.
Apparently been happening
many, many times.
they've got a weird spaceship houseboat.
the Howard Dean scream that he references
is to the politician in real life, Howard
Dean,
who actually screamed during a speech
he was giving in the speech
he gave was called
I Have a Scream, a big parody of Martin
Luther King's I Have a Dream speech
the robot looks kind of like a parody
of Rosie the robot from The Jetsons.
the more he keeps dropping more references
to his underworld contacts,
because apparently
some huge person in the world of crime
now don't know if that's
going to continue to be a story runner
this season or this is like a one off date
for this particular episode, the swamp
bit here is just a joke on airboat chases.
There have been a ton in TV
shows and movies.
You can let me know if you think it's
a reference to a specific movie.
Then they turn themselves into like this
Cronenberg combo creation
creature that's supposed to be like
the perfect being.
it's also meant to pay off
the title of the episode,
The Generic Trap,
because they call themselves a generic,
and the idea is that they turn themselves
into like this perfect creation.
That's why they have a sonic abilities.
They can do pretty much anything.
They can hear atoms
splitting in space. R.I.P.
to all the mobsters.
And then on their way back when Summer's
clowning on podcast being super lame,
that feels like Dan Harmon
making a Harmon Town joke like Louie.
Let's not listen to that.
the crows
he references is a callback to Rick and
two crows from Rick and Morty season five
we basically replaced the family
with the two crows and just left earth
to go on adventures with them,
which is threatening to do now.
When Gene has his big moment,
he is correct.
Nobody in the family
cares about him at all.
then the whole bit with the memory,
Rick's stuck inside them.
There's trying to save their personalities
I think is meant to be in Inception
reference, like running around inside
people's minds what he says.
The memory of him is from 30 years ago.
That's the time when he was still
wandering around the galaxy.
When he first met bird person from all
the flashbacks we saw in previous seasons,
the Rick orders Morty to go sell more
crystals for him confirming he was buying
the big by that Morty got caught doing
earlier Beth goes operate on more horses.
Like I said
they're just paying off the joke
that she does have a regular day job
that they never really address.
In a lot of the recent seasons.
they zoom out notice in the backyard,
there's all of the graves
in the beginning of season
six episode one,
that was just the joke that the family
had to move to another reality
and replace the family
that was already there.
Again,
that itself was just meant to be building
on top of the previous similar types
of bits that break it down.
Like we can only pack up and move
to other realities a couple more times.
Morty Like the joke will get boring
after a couple more times.
then the Rick and Jerry episode
with a scene of their picture
as burger and fries at a bar
they got kicked out of just to reference
them being friends, basically.
in the Post-Credits
scene is just the memory.
Rick, who's still stuck inside
Jerry's mind, now also surmising that Rick
actually stuck him or stranded him inside
Jerry's mind when he thinks their minds
maybe he remembers something
that Rick doesn't want to get out.
You let me know in the comments, like,
why would Rick strand him inside
Jerry's mind?
But the other joke here, too,
is that Jerry, because he's so simple
minded, just thinks that all
machines are made up of springs.
So every time he opens up a machine,
all it comes out
is just a bunch of springs,
which he's using to turn into sculptures
having to live next to memory.
Gene when you start
looking around the frame here too,
like all the different spring sculptures
that he creates are basically recreating
all the people in real life.
But like this person,
it seems like it's fighting an alien.
These are a bunch of flowers.
There's a much irregular stuff
mixed with really WTF there
there's so many Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if you think you've spotted
any that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
And my full Episode 3 video, we'll post
next week, click here for my brand new
Invincible Season 2 trailer video
new episodes for that really soon
and click here for my Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 1 Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!